joining us from the world series is the
commissioner of baseball rob manfred how
are you commissioner
i'm good rich how are you i'm doing just
fine uh i don't know if you just heard
the story i told about paul tagliabue
um that he roots the team that's losing
because he wants for a close game
uh i imagine you could not even
envisioned the way a game four could
could finish up uh over the world i
always do for the team that's behind in
the series um i think long series
like the great seven game series we had
in the nlcs and alcs are good for the
sport
and you know tampa was behind in the
series saturday night but it was a great
finish
to the ball game i mean just a
phenomenal
baseball game all the way around now i
know so how do you are you
you're in the stadium are you watching
it in the stadium just like everybody
else yeah i've been i've been at i
actually um i visited all the division
series sites saw at least one game
in each of the division series rounds
and then came back down here for the
beginning of the world series i've been
at all the games and
i'm here until we're done and i'm again
i'm just wondering what it what is it
like for you to see something like that
unfold
in front of you the rest of the country
is going crazy over
uh right well you know it it was really
interesting um
i was in uh the ballpark with a a couple
of the guys
that work with me and you know between
the three of us
we watch all the time a ton of baseball
and over the years have seen a ton of
baseball
and i'm not sure um i've seen a more
unique
and exciting end to a baseball game ever
i mean it was just
just all the things that happened is
series of events that seemed
impossible you know i know and again uh
i know you're you're in charge of the
sport
so but you know uh talking to you like
you're a fan
because you are one of those as well i
mean just the story of brett phillips
too the fact that he
didn't hit 200 for either team including
the team that put him at the plate
um uh all season long put him at the
plate in the biggest at-bat of his life
he didn't even play in the lcs round
he's out there
um you know as a defensive replacement
essentially on this roster and he's put
in that spot and he puts one into play
and then
all sorts of craziness breaks out like
that you can't you can't script it
no you can't script it and just the pure
emotion
of what happened if you watch brett
himself i mean
after um the play unfolded i mean
if that show of emotion is
what sport is about i think it's one of
the things that makes baseball so great
um just the pure joy of you know
winning such an unlikely um or achieving
such an unlikely victory
was really fun to watch all right rob
manford major league baseball
commissioner here on the rich eisen show
prior to
game six after an exhilarating weekend
of the world series
um if i told you um back in june
that you'd be in this position uh one
day potentially if not two definitely
away from handing out the trophy
uh in a bubble in texas you would have
said what
would you sign for it yeah i would have
if you told me that um we would finish
up in a bubble and and that's the way we
were going to finish
i would have accepted that result very
happily
um you know we entered the season with a
lot of trepidation rich we knew it was
going to be a massive challenge
but we were really lucky um in some
respects but
you know it's also a lot of hard work
and sacrifice for our players
club officials you know my staff
the experts that worked with us that
allowed us to get through this
and um you know i do think it's
important in the game that we have a
2020 world series champion
well i mean you're about to have one um
but uh
did did you think it might not happen at
some point there were points in time
where
we were really concerned about our
ability to pull it off yeah 100
rich i mean you know after the um
after the second outbreak um you know we
had the marlins and then the cardinals
we were really concerned about where we
were and a lot of people
stepped up tony clark helped us
made the protocols not only stiffer but
really worked with us in terms of
making sure the players were adhering to
them um i think that the staffs at the
club
got much more aggressive and we were
able to
to hold it together rob manfred baseball
commissioner here on the rich eisen show
last time you and i spoke in person was
at the super bowl i saw you
uh prior to kickoff of that game and
now here we are uh you're about to
complete your season uh the nfl
is in the middle of the season those are
the two sports that did not bubble up
have you in the nfl had conversations at
all
uh about getting through a season not
bubbled up has there been any sort of
dovetailing between protocols there's
been a lot of conversation
among the four major professional sports
the pga tour um about you know what
works what doesn't work
um you know and it goes back to before
any of us started playing i mean
obviously um our situations were very
different
some of the sports were in a position
where the the bubble kind of setup was
workable we looked really hard at it
um and just decided because of
facilities and
the amount of time involved that we
couldn't make it work
but we've tried to be generous in terms
of sharing
our learning with other sports and the
other sports have certainly been
generous with us
well uh how have you been generous with
the nfl again that they're
they're week seven like i'm sure your
your colleague and friend roger goodell
would sign for a piece of paper
that he would be giving out the lombardi
trophy um and i would be having this
conversation with him two days before
super sunday i'm sure he would sign that
right now
what what conversations have you had
specifically um the
the conversations have um
with roger have been at the conceptual
level our staffs have had more detailed
conversations about
things you know probably the single
biggest topic
was dealing with a positive test
what do you do to make sure it doesn't
spread obviously
i think you know whatever issues there
have been in both sports
really important that we have not had
spread
on the field in either sport
um but you know it's those practical
scientific problems that you know have
have been the bulk of the conversation
between the leagues rob manfred here on
the rich eyes and show what aspect of
2020
for the major league baseball season any
of the advents do you think is most
likely to stick
well i i think i think the expanded
playoffs
is something we were interested in
before the pandemic began
i don't think it's going to look like it
looked this year 16 teams
too many for us i think we've been
historically more
selective in terms of the postseason but
i like the idea playing
two out of three games um i loved that
week where
you know there was just baseball kind of
around the clock i think it was really
good
for us and i think by using a smaller
number of teams something more than 10
but less than 16
we can structure the playoffs in a way
that preserves the significance of our
regular season makes the teams play hard
all the way through the end but gives us
the
kind of excitement we had during that
first week of the postseason
what about putting a man in scoring
position to start a um
to start an extra inning what do you
think of that idea that's been
you know i haven't decided on what my
personal
position on that's going to be i will
say this i think that um
the x-rating rule has some traction
within the game i think the players
were positive about it i think our fans
were positive about it
it does create focus and strategy
late in the game and brings a you know
more definitive
end to the game and i think even some of
the most conservative
members of the media actually after they
saw it operate a few times recognize the
merits of the rule
um whether it survives or not i'm not
going to speculate on it
you know i'm i'm a lucky guy that i get
to talk to a lot of people in this
position
uh from you commissioner manfred to fans
wanting to call in i haven't spoken to a
single person that says boy do i miss
pitchers hitting
boy do i miss when that pitcher gets in
there in that nine spot
and squares up and moves the runner over
do you think that that is also
maybe something you'd consider uh yeah i
do yeah i do
um you know obviously all these changes
need to be negotiated with the players
association um i i think you know any
rule
where or rule change where people look
at it and say
you know what just from a safety and
health perspective this may be a better
rule for our game i think the dh kind of
falls in that category
keep pitchers off the base path they're
really valuable
and you know look i think a little more
offense
in every part of our game probably not a
bad thing but that's another one that
we'll get some discussion
and then uh a question that i cause i
i've sent out uh to my friends uh
across the country hey i got the
commissioner coming on today is there
anything you you think i should ask him
friends of mine on the east coast want
to know about maybe an earlier start
time
to world series games we just spent the
beginning beginning portion of our
conversation about what a remarkable
finish that was to game four
stroke of midnight for kids sitting
there in tampa florida probably fast
asleep
is there any what are you thinking about
bringing
new younger fans in maybe with something
like well
let me deal with start times first i
mean i i i think that
um whenever we set a start time we set
start times with our broadcast partners
that are designed to get the largest
possible audience um for
you know our most important games we
could play
more daytime postseason base
games than any other sport i mean you
just think about the first round right
the two out of three series you could
watch a game
you know from noon on to any point in
the day
i i think there is a little bit
of a misimpression on this issue
our younger audiences
are not diminished in
prime time start games the numbers
are about the same as the earlier start
times
that we have during the initial rounds
of the playoffs
and again the real key from our
perspective
is to get the largest possible audience
um
watching our most important games all
right last one for you commissioner this
may be somewhat uh unprofessional of me
but i'm asking a question on behalf of
my
friend across the way here who's a die
hard fan of the
boston red sox is there any way you
could void the mookie bets trade is
there any way
is there anything is there is there
anything
is there anything that's looked in the
fine print i understand
why he feels that way uh mookie has had
he had a great season and an
unbelievable postseason
um but uh i think he's the los angeles
dodgers for the time being and you're
gonna have to accept that yeah
it's been approved right it's been
approved it's uh it's all settled
he is a dodger right he should chris you
need to take solace in the fact you're
getting free tacos
um yes you know oh yes you should soak
that in
you should soak that in you always have
to he's not taking advantage of that
just yet
commissioner thank you for the time
appreciate it uh enjoy the afternoon
good to talk to you i hope i'll talk to
you again soon you got it that's it you
bet that's my uh
my my uh my friend the commissioner
rob manfred sorry chris it's settled
it's it's a matter of settled it's a
matter of seven we tried
what more can i do we tried then ask
the man in charge of the sport if the
trade can be voted
maybe just maybe there's a receipt lying
around somewhere
some type of loophole something
something in the drawer that you forgot
you put aside
by the way two days to those three tacos
28th oh
all right is that what it is yup it's
28th thanks up to then no no on that day
you get the free time
28th taco day that's the taco yeah but
doesn't that mean there's going to be a
run
a whole country is going to show up for
their tacos oh they do they don't care
taco bell get ready that's what they
they got to prepare social distance well
get your tacos
unless i go wednesday no maybe adam gase
just picks it up for everybody
lebron's not happy it's wednesday yeah
he likes talking
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here